- Oh my god.
Where do we start?
- What is the
- Ok. We're ok.
- Oh poor
- I'm going to fluff this up.
- Oh.
(laughs)
- Like this a little bit.
- Dammit!
- Yes! Yes.
- No regrets.
- I mean it's my face.
So what's the worst that could happen?
(cheerful strings)
- I'm nervous, but excited.
- I'm just really nervous, actually.
- Just as long as there
aren't any tweezers.
I think it's all
- Do we have tweezers?
- No!
- I feel so excited.
Nick is a beautiful man.
He's going to make me look
like a beautiful lady.
- I hope.
(laughs)
- We're going from a nine to a ten,
as far as I'm concerned.
- And may the best woman win!
- [Voiceover] Three, two, one.
Go.
- Oh my God.
Where do we start?
- I don't know.
Wait.
What are these things?
- Is this lip gloss?
- I don't know how of this
to put on the little brush.
- Do you know what this is?
Is it foundation?
- Founder.
- Oh. Ok.
- That's foundation right?
- Yea.
- You already look so much better you do.
(laughs)
I forget though.
Does this go on like both?
(laughs)
- Oh God!
- Let me just.
- Oh Lord have mercy!
(laughs)
- Oh my God!
- Are you sure that's
what you're doing to her?
Ooh Lord.
- I think it's...
Let me take some of that off.
- Ok.
- I'm just going to do
one side of your face.
I forgot there were two.
- How does she look?
Is she looking good?
- If you were trying to come
out with me with this makeup?
Like, girl go home.
(laughs)
I mean look.
This bitch is drawing
(laughs)
- Wow, you look so good.
Ok. Hold on one second.
- It's just been, like, foundation, right?
That's all that's happened.
- It might collect right
here because I'm crying.
(laughs)
So all the powder may congeal.
- All right.
- Is this for lips?
Or for eyes?
- For eyeliner.
- Ooh. Let's use it as your lips.
- When you make a mistake,
you just rub it in.
- Can you put mascara on your eyebrows?
(laughs)
- Yea.
- Do people do that?
I think people do that, right?
- Some people do that.
- Oh, wait.
You can do that?
- Oh no!
(laughs)
- Do you like that?
- I don't like anything any more.
(laughs)
- Don't make eye contact
with me right now.
(laughs
- Mine looks hot.
Look at her.
She's like going to get fucked tonight.
(laughs)
- Ok.
This is kind of working now, right?
Somebody say yes.
- Yes.
- Thank you.
- Wow.
Ok, you just fucked it up!
- I'm sorry!
- What the fuck?
- Isn't
Wait.
Aren't you like supposed
to smack your lips?
- No!
- Honey.
- How do I look?
(laughs)
- We did it!
- I think I won.
(laughs)
- Hold on.
You look amazing!
- Isn't she hot?
- But it's like my grandma's
make up a little bit.
- I mean, yea.
She's a little bit casket
sharp but whatever.
(laughs)
(suspenseful music)
- I kind of wanted to
get a little creative,
and I was like yea.
Let's try to blend the colors up here.
And then I wanted to give her,
make her lips, like kind of
push through a little bit more,
so I'm like, "Yea, some lip liner.".
Much like my sister used
to do in the early '90s.
- Holy shit!
(laughs)
- It's not that bad, right?
- Wow.
- Look.
All you got to do is put
a nice filter on there.
- Dude, what the fuck with the eyebrows?
Seriously?
- That's my favorite part.
- I did a little bit of
everything to Britney here.
We started with the eye.
Wanted to give her a
nice smoky purple eye.
Then I got an idea from
Curly to outline her brows
with something.
And I think they just
really pop off that face.
(laughs)
- Oh
You think my lip ends right here?
(laughs)
No, yea.
These eyebrows definitely pop off my face.
(laughs)
- Well, on the bright
side, I didn't get any
in your eye or on your teeth.
- That is true.
- [Voiceover] Yea, same over here.
- So we won.
Love wins.
- Look how good she looks.
The lips?
They clearly pop.
The eyes?
Bam.
But she kind of looks dead.
Ok, girl.
- Oh ok.
(laughs)
You know what?
This is fucking great.
I look beautiful.
(playful strings)
I mean if the theory is that it's fun
to have gay men give you a
makeover, like that's true.
If it's that they'll do a
good job, well, maybe not.
- Yea. It's not true.
- Clearly.
(laughs)
- Clearly false.
- Can't do it.
- But lots of confidence.
(mumbles)
- You look so pretty.
If I liked women, I
would be all over that.
(laughs)
- So not convincing.
- You're lying.
- I'd be all up in that.
(laughs)
(indistinct cheer)